welcome to Jim Gordon it's Sam Roberts
[Music]
hey my wife's vagina smells good morning
it's Bill Clinton and Sam Roberts
sticking drugs
bill we're on the air oh what a great
story so much going on this morning Bob
Kelly will be here there's an awesome
Donald Trump clip that we have to play
but yeah I mean I thought of you as soon
as I read this story did Bill Clinton's
longtime lover which like you don't know
if it's true right but I don't not
believe it sure from 70s in the 80s yeah
it's a one of Bill Clinton's longtime
lovers revealed how bill boom owned his
sex life with his wife because she had
greasy hair body odor but she wanted a
baby to dispel the rampant lesbian
[Laughter]
wanted a baby so badly so that people
would stop calling you a lesbian when
you just wash your [ __ ] hair some
kind of art of seduction being done yeah
I told her to gargle your mouth smells
like clothes it's like just wash under
your arms you know I mean like and and
and lesbians it doesn't mean you don't
shower just because you're a lesbian I
mean women appreciate somebody that
smells good as well Hillary came to me
why not she said Bell to calling me a
doc around the office and his lungs just
sitting there like bill there's a lot of
information you're unloading on me is it
really that bad my wife's table smells
like the underside of the wig
[Laughter]
it says Bill Clinton is a sex addicted
mother zucchini in her vagina you know
if your this says Bill Clinton is a sex
addicted quote monster if you're a sex
addicted monster and your wife's body
odor is too bad and hair is too greasy
to have sex with we're in trouble yeah
my wife smelled too bad I had to go in
the kitchen and [ __ ] tuna sir he said
bill mocked Hillary Clinton by calling
her the warden in front of his friends
and privately boasted about his high
knotch count according to his longtime
mistress and childhood friend dolly Kyle
why don't you just talk to your wife
about it I can't smell like [ __ ] she
coughing got pubic hair in my face and
it wasn't a men's pubic hair no the 68
year old woman Dolly Kyle says she had a
decades-long affair with the former
president oh that's DK that looks like
back with the former president before
and during his marriage and had a front
row seat to build salacious double life
in the 70s and 80s bill had a double
life because his wife was a stinky
[Laughter]
Crisco their on-again off-again
relationship ended abruptly in the 1990s
after Bill Clinton allegedly threatened
to destroy Kyle if she spoke to the
media about their relationship Clinton
looks weird when you look at the old
pictures of him like in the 70s yeah
that's full head of hair
Wak he looks weird with jet-black hair
yeah he does let go down the garden keep
going the one of the ones we just saw
you it looks like he looks like a young
black man right right there he's had jet
black weird it looked weird on him it's
weird for both of them
looking at Hillary and Bill Young
because they becomes such political
monsters that the idea that they were
ever like young human beings is alarming
I'm looking at a young photo of Hillary
Clinton though I could see her having
stinky pits absolutely you know I could
see her putting that backpack on going
for a sweaty walk and maybe not applying
antiperspirant properly yeah she spends
all day lawyer and that gets into bed
smells like a homeless person yeah she's
sitting there with her with her sport
coat on arguing in a court of law
you know her hands are moving all over
the place and she's getting all
passionate about trying to get somebody
off but what happens she gets all sweaty
and she doesn't like deodorant I raped a
girl she got her all that she put her
dirty [ __ ] on my face dolly said that
the clintons attacks on her reputation
and alleged attacks on other women who
had relationships with or were assaulted
by Bill Clinton showed that Hillary
Clinton is not a supporter of women or
sexual of of sexual violence yeah she's
not a supporter of sexualized oh she's
not a supporter of women who are victims
of sexual violence yeah I would say if
Hillary is trying to silence a woman who
was abused because she doesn't want her
coming out about being a lesbian with
greasy hair yeah that's probably a bit
selfish yeah it really is my mom's hair
smells like a foot and looks like wet
spaghetti another worse than greasy hair
and Olman Oh gracias
it's just names you don't wash Dinks
greasy hair Hilary used to just slick
her hair back but there was no product
in it no it's just grease natural bill
your body is built to clean itself oh
I'd say your body the vaginas like a
self-cleaning oven she'd learned all
that all our cleaning tips from her let
being friends Hilary would just be like
no you know Laura was telling me that
you don't actually it's actually bad for
your scalp to shampoo once a week I
don't do it that often you don't need to
clean it for him that time enjoy the way
you are yeah it's at history it's her
story and your story is about having
hair the way God put it on your head
there's a lot of the women that like
that are the hippie vent ality they
think that it's gonna self clean in the
body you don't shouldn't shower too much
it doesn't sting keep it that wouldn't
bother me that bothers in the body does
not South clean if a woman I get it
having a little bit of an aroma but
you're saying if she had legit stinky
pits like this is a woman with body odor
it doesn't bother you it depends on what
the body chemistry is sometimes it
really turns me on really like like bad
like this stinks yeah like body odor
yeah I said let me make my exhale but my
ex-girlfriend should tell it don't put
deodorant on uh-huh until she stung and
we were walking in a restaurant and
people were turning and looking at her
she smelled so bad oh oh so how'd you
liked it went crazy how's your little
turn-on yeah maybe not Robert Kelly I'm
gonna fish I'm gonna face your guests
I saw you showing the pants let you know
in case you likewise I walked in cuz I
have the pen you got the pants yes you
do they're so funny you're talking about
stinking yeah I hate that you don't like
it you love it I do on the right person
the chemistry is good I enjoy what does
that mean
sometimes body chemistry is weird so
when you kiss somebody sometimes their
mouth tastes weird like if you have good
body chemistry with somebody I like that
smell
so is it because everybody has a
different smell or just hits you
different smells like Bob's omelette
there's a story about one of Bill
Clinton's ex-lovers you know from the
70s and 80s and she's coming forward and
saying the bill used to always complain
to her because Hillary had body odor and
greasy hair and what she wanted she
wanted to get knocked up because she
wanted people to stop calling her a
lesbian but bill didn't want to have sex
with her because she stunk and greasy
hair was like [ __ ] a Reuben I like
Reubens but if a girl smelled like one I
wouldn't like it that's a good right now
Roomba is one of my favorite things
but if a girl smelled like what I throw
up you love Rubens but would you want to
impregnate one I don't think so probably
not I would want to even ask that smelly
birthday cake like great food I would
not like no I would like it to be a
little human I'm not a food guy I don't
like food and sex either that makes me
puke
like nine and a half weeks when they
[ __ ] by the fridge and they pour it
all that stuff oh yeah yeah do they put
food on each other yeah whipped cream
and chocolate sauce it's nothing for me
neither try to sauce they're a [ __ ]
looks like [ __ ] just a sticky mess
[ __ ] a bad taco yeah I don't like food I
don't want any whipped cream on the
nipple now because the you can see that
varsity blues scene isn't that the movie
varsity blues when I think Ali Larter
maybe came out wearing a whipped cream
bikini and everybody went nuts for her
oh my god so sexy what I gotta do to get
her naked throw water on her that's a
nice [ __ ] bikini disappears like the
witch yeah and then it goes down into
her vagina and then her butt juice mix
yeah that's some sweet tangy yeah
tangy metallicky that's kind of sexy
though because she's pretty naked under
that that's sexy because it's just high
that's the only thing between you and
her tits is whipped cream but you're
right though you go down on her and even
if you catch like a hint of whipped
cream down there you're like oh this is
leftovers and before you think I'd love
that yeah no I got my thing but you know
you have separate interests yeah III
compartmentalize right yeah there's a
spot for food and a spot for sex is that
Hillary yeah what shoot that bad back
there her hair does not look greasy it
looks dried out in that photo but it
doesn't look greasy yeah it looks very
dry looks very dry Halloween wig it
looks very dry but it doesn't look
greasy but this is a very young photo of
her this is when she was in college and
and I could definitely she's wearing
like pants and a smart shirt I could see
her having stinky pits in that photo
she's probably dead though
I bet Hillary's good in bed if you're a
girl girls for Bill you think they ever
had a threesome No
did Billy foot here Hilary getting
walked off the bed being pushed off by
Bill's ass how about when they were
younger they did and then they tried to
do it once when they were older but they
started having second thoughts and they
had the third person killed mothball
smell oh that's my my chicks [ __ ] yeah
the garbage stop Hilary turned the fan
[Laughter]
but he probably liked it back then like
he probably when he was young he
probably didn't mind that Hilary stunk
she was like a hippie but when he got
older and he got a little power cuz you
get the power you get the women well
that happens with Fame too I mean a lot
of guys before the famous little nerdy
they're banging like theater chicks yeah
like dumpy girls and then they get this
fame and all of a sudden they're banging
11s right once you realize you can get a
sweet-smelling dolly Kyle Donnelly's the
one that came out it's probably she's
probably a dish back in 1974 though look
at her she was yeah yeah she was [ __ ]
hot Darla's Cal that blabbermouth can
you side by side those girls
what dolly Kyle and young Hillary
Clinton yeah you know just to see where
you measure up sometimes you feel like a
nut sometimes you don't right right my
wife smells like you saying baby I can't
keep an erection
yeah but bill can I just say something
okay bill didn't deserve the chick on
the left was there whatever her name is
no he didn't just he wasn't that
good-looking either he was an ugly he
was Hillary's they should go to you he's
a very charming dude he can talk you
know he can think that that that that
little rock arkansas a used car salesman
thing going for him
oh yeah and in Little Rock as soon as he
started getting political power he
started to become a dude yeah guy you
know what I mean but he okay yeah
exactly but he doesn't deserve her
his
right no no he had to do a lot extra if
he worked at you know a you know helping
children right you forget a YMCA forget
on macaroni vases someone sweet as a
photo of them when they were younger
it's not weird to see them together like
that bill with a beard you know a few
pounds overweight with two beards yeah
because when you actually see them they
together they could literally both be
the front like you can literally be
standing with two presents United States
is ours are they look like that so when
you see them young also like cuz you
know for years they've been planning
some kind of the this political takeover
they've had political aspirations for a
very long time when you see them young
it's like you wonder at what point did
they become [ __ ] Clair and Frank
Underwood you know what I mean like when
you see they're just kids and they might
have actually been in love at some point
I'm sure they were in love there those
are all a Polly cheek he's probably this
bill was to [ __ ] at that point though
he's like another chance [ __ ] wipe it
odor is wafting about bill is happy in
that photo because he's getting laid
that night indeed apple pie Melania
Trump vagina clothes hillary worry
that's what she stunk she was literally
wearing curtains you think bill would
complain that Hillary's pits wouldn't
stink as bad if she wasn't wearing a
Paul Street [ __ ] dress is a
Scotchgarded you think bill has made any
inappropriate comments about Melania
Trump sure in this election [ __ ]
hilarious
she says the two became good friends and
dated casually through high school while
later began a sexual affair in 1974
after
and her first husband divorce this is
Dolly Kyle Hillary at UH at college in
college yeah she's I mean she saw
smoking back I mean she is really hot
dolly Kyle is throwing her under the bus
let me tell you something looks good
yeah you know but dolly Kyle thought she
was gonna end up with Bill that's why
she's got venom in her listen to this
quote dolly now years laters from the
70s as a woman in her 60s she goes to
whatever this was the Daily Mail and she
says she was shocked by Hillary's
unkempt appearance poor hydrant but poor
hygiene and matronly clothes and didn't
believe it was the same girl the bill it
moved in with matronly young age really
she's a terrible dresser and bad hygiene
Hillary's a terrible dresser it's really
bad when they say you have bad hygiene
cuz then it's like you're just not
accomplishing a life skill you know what
I mean like you don't have the ability
you don't wash yeah you know you have
poor hygiene my wife's gonna smell like
dried sweat you know she's done I've
said this before but the older women get
they they start to dress like starship
commanders with the jacket Captain Kirk
with it they all have smart jackets with
the shoulder buttons I'll show the pads
and like you know [ __ ] some type of
some type of metal they won yeah didn't
win pantsuits do they look like women's
pants look like futuristic men's suits
yeah Hillary is the worst with that
though her outfit sir because it's all
the same color from head to toe keep it
down
my wife's home I think I hear there's a
bit monochromatic with your sound board
Jimmy we can't trust you with the
gadgets we won't give them to you hey
Marsh didn't upset with you over there
broke something I love it something goes
and Mars gives this look like what that
[ __ ] idiot do this like that sounds
bad I hope I can fix it this is a dolly
Kyle says she picked up I picked up
Billy at the airport this is just she
calls him Billy now just ever just to
really drive the point home how familiar
they were you know what I mean she says
I picked Billy up at the airport and he
had this
dotty looking middle-aged woman with him
this woman was Hilary oh my god she's
trashing Hilary bill is shocked when she
I can't believe my wife took a shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
she said the worst dresser she goes I
thought it was a guardians of the galaxy
with that long coat the good pastor
knees
Joseph wear that coat it really is it's
a Technicolor Dreamcoat isn't it nobody
should wear coats male or female that go
past your knees I live here in our band
yeah you're in a band right you're in a
band you can wear that [ __ ] but if
you're not you can't if you're in a band
or if you're gonna shoot up a high
school in Colorado is garbage exactly
she wearing rugs and [ __ ] God made the
curtain thing in Egypt dolly says I
thought it was a Hilary impersonator
because she looked so bad and she
smelled so bad
camouflage her shirts look like smocks
yeah yeah Wow I mean what are you gonna
do I mean you can't you gotta you can do
better than Hilary's doing especially if
she stinks which we're finding out today
in the news apparently she reportedly
does stink yeah today still I believe so
no is that real people saying that she
smells dolly dolly Kyle right now is
just speaking to her time in saying she
was a woman who couldn't dress and smell
bad probably back to then but not
there's no way there's no way she smells
now and in the middle when she was the
first lady yeah they actually made she
actually started looking a lot better
she glasses off her hair wasn't done it
wasn't that hey hair right she actually
looked alright when she was the first
lady she wasn't that bad yeah she was
right there to the left he bill actually
made he went to the lady goes make this
[ __ ] look like somebody I gotta tell
you something but he's styled her to
look a little more like dolly County
yeah he looks look at that he he gave
Hillary
he said dolly Harry gave her a picture
of dollars and make her look like this
make her look like dolly make her smell
like this she stinks
my wife smells like Noir you think
Hillary didn't wash your vagina oh it
was probably sounds like a fruit I think
she smells like a JetBlue sandwich it's
been pre-made and just sitting in a
drawer for two days is those purple
onions she smells like purple I know she
can't get a break huh she's almost
president yeah but she still I mean she
doesn't need people coming out and
saying she did that and this woman's
also saying dolly saying she was a sex
addict and so was Bill like Dolly was a
sex addict Hilary was not Hillary was
she said she doesn't know if Hillary was
a lesbian but she knows that Hillary
wanted a kid okay and that's another
thing like if you're Chelsea Clinton do
you want to read an article that's like
oh they decided to have me so that
nobody would think my mom who is a
lesbian do you think do you think she
thinks she'll seeing Hillary had to talk
about they pi don't pay attention but
you know there's not one moment where
Chelsea did she really just right right
there so people wouldn't Hillary's like
ro another one of these [ __ ]
articles right Chelsey and Chelsey is
like yeah
just looking at her mother like there's
too many of these to not be true
don't stink when I was a little girl in
the kitchen a party's in our house
smelled like a diner you look like a
dish used to chuck deodorants at me and
said these are for your mom my wife's
vagina smells like linoleum after you've
cleaned vomit office puke smell that
lingers huh hey what if none of it's
true you know that she didn't never
stunk it all never stuck they were in
love from the beginning right he banged
one chick by it you know and got caught
and the Hillary and they had the best
family left she was great in bed they
[ __ ] all the time right and none of
its truth is yeah I think that there's
very little chance of that happening
here's the one confirmed case is him
shoving a cigar up in interns [ __ ] you
don't start with that exactly know what
that cigar was by using a cut like a
humidor years of extramarital frolicking
like a bourbon we're talking yesterday
if I wanted to get a billboard for this
show I think that needs to be our
tagline yeah you don't start by using a
[ __ ] like a humidor my god yeah no I
don't I think that bill uh why would he
stick a cigar and a [ __ ] I get it
he's the president and he's done it all
he's just being dirty you don't wanna
take this later I'll bet it was how it
made it dirtier cuz it's illegal oh yeah
he said you know I'm not even supposed
to have these then right uh port white
at once yeah that was the role-playing
game that they went that the police were
coming in and bill was like where am I
gonna hide the cigars Lynch I gotta go
out there yeah surface waiting for that
so he can think of any smoked when he
smoked it in front of his wife and his
friend he could think of her he probably
he probably dipped the the the lit side
so when he smoked it smell he tasted her
[ __ ] oh yeah you think that you think
that he would smoke the cigars with
Monica in the room and
front of his wife and then that way him
and Monica would know you know Hillary
didn't smell it
I don't know Hillary may have a sixth
sense for that type of stuff
damn Hillary keeps eating my cigars
Hillary it looks like a bad dog he walks
into the room like what happened to the
cigars and Hillary just has a cigar
debris all over chin gone I don't know
yeah I heard a clunk and I caught her
routed through the humidor Hillary said
I'd get [ __ ] as long as I dip cigars
and [ __ ] that's a favorite treat I just
put a candle on his cigar he just you
just had to keep fixing their cigars for
her vagina on the cigar no but you know
some of them you would you know you know
what I mean I'm sure it's just a
psychological thing I think you'd smell
monica's you think so yeah she's a kind
of big girl here's a chubby girl for
sure every girl probably hot she's thick
it's probably hot depends on what time
of day it was oh yeah she just get to
the office did she take the train oh no
[ __ ] it would have been a an evening
after a day of wearing a wool dress you
know wow wow you smell bad yeah yeah
yeah no I think it was I think there was
there was something psychological about
him smoking the cigar while Hillary was
in the room and Monica was in there too
wow she looks good now Monica uh-huh
yeah she looks good I mean back then she
was uh she looked like no she looked
like bills type she was like she was
like kind of a WoW chubby a little
trashy bangs you know what I mean she
looks good really good now yeah she does
look good now is she married and imagine
that that'd be a tough one to get over
try to get a blood no I'd love it she
tried a blow job you'll come on great
like to give you tough to get over if it
really white yeah yeah and your Costco
and every over looking at your wife and
kid look familiar
yeah if the lie uh I'd be fine with it
on a personal level but not you're right
the public thing of people coming up to
you be like Oh your wife's the one the
blue oh shift she'd have to get shirts
since I suck the president's dick right
just to get it out of the way
to get in just to be in on it right just
so just said this is on the table that
fat Linda strip ruined everything
yeah she did bill was having a hell of a
time what does she look like now Linda
Tripp why I I hope her hotness held up
she was really cute she actually looks a
lot of [ __ ] together she was such a
monster look at her up there she looks
turn oh yeah she [ __ ] do you think
she was flattered that SN out remember
when I used to do parodies of her do you
remember who played her John Goodman I
think she was flattered that John may
pick John Goodman to player on the right
I mean it looks like John Goodman
yeah Jack give me would be a good pick I
mean look at that photo she looks much
better she's hiding the neck with that
thing she was and she's a ton of plastic
surgery she looks like [ __ ] nice
Charla Nash after the chimp attack was
you all put together look exactly to
Lorne Michaels is responsible for that
woman having all that plastic surgery a
hundred percent jump John Goodman makes
her look really fat and ugly
[Laughter]
being a lady being a woman being born
female you're a woman you have a
femininity about you and you're like oh
I guess SNL is gonna skewer me this week
I wonder who they're gonna pick to play
me maybe and you turn it on and it's not
any of the a-list actresses it's John
Goodman yeah man that's insulting could
you imagine could you imagine being her
friends having to lie you look like John
Goodman you know you're not aligned
think about the John Goodman pick is
it's not even funny it doesn't look like
you so it's not funny no more like
Gerard Depardieu French stink but when
she's not around they're all laughing at
it huh there are having the time in
their lives
it says Bill CLEP kept it's a Gurkha
cigars no Gurkha cigars watch you
they're very nice
naari they very nice guy yeah I mean he
kept satella inside sources have
confirmed that the Gurkha cigars were
indeed the cigars used between Monica
Lewinsky and Bill Clinton I would have
used the grand cajon a tattoo why
a very big one I called the Wesley
Snipes when I put it in my mouth is that
what you fantasize about it actually
changed the end of it goes from ashy to
nice dark black you put in your mouth
Jim DOS weird quick got very real very
fast well why would Monica tell anyone
that he put the cigar in her [ __ ] Bill
Clinton didn't offer that up they think
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman I did put a cigar in her
[ __ ]
yeah is that cheating that's not
technically sex he didn't say that no
why would she have said that she thought
this is Monica had her own problems she
thought she was having girl talk with
Linda Tripp and she recorded it and she
recorded it under my flower lapel yeah
yeah that's what I said
SNL would have John Goodman is Linda
Tripp and just like sitting basically on
top of her going like what was that
Monica and just pointing the the broach
yeah right at her face when the trip is
gross yeah yeah but she recorded her
telling the story she thought she was
just confiding in Linda why would Linda
Tripp know that she was gonna tell her
something and why would she make it
obvious she talked to him before yeah so
she talked to her before and then
figured I'm gonna get this on tape well
yeah because Linda had a bone to pick
with bill and where do you get a flower
lapel microphone the spy store I mean
back because back then and now it's so
easy you just have every day as a phone
you could do but back then it was pretty
hard but in the 90s they had like
brick-and-mortar spy store oh yeah but
you could go into the spy store that was
on the corner you know none of the [ __ ]
worked once it was terrible the old pen
recorder yeah exactly yeah click never
the pen was huge it look like it look
like any pen that exists at all good
hold on your shoulder like a camera
plus there was like one sentence worth
of ink in it cuz it had to be full of
electronic so nobody could borrow it
like it was it was it was the most
suspicious pen Walt
there's no branding on it anywhere you
couldn't hear anything and then you had
no idea how to get the audio off of it
[Laughter]
it's hard to tell from the recording but
she's saying that the president shoved a
cigar her [ __ ]
yeah but she obviously had a major bone
to pick because she went to all the
trouble of recording that conversation
did she tell it to I don't remember who
who did she go to and Linda Tripp yeah I
don't know I think she went gone to the
press with it first she just immediately
went to the press I think that was the
plan I love that it backfired though and
everybody hated her she hated Linda
Tripp for that I'm right it was more cuz
she recorded kids Monica was a young
dumb intern ya courted her and at least
you could be like wow you know Monica
was doing what Monica was doing whatever
but Linda Tripp was the one person who's
being absolutely malicious about the
whole thing
she went to the news right yes she went
immediately to the press how much money
did she make did she make anything I'm
sure she didn't make enough that's it's
mainly Shiite tapes the Kenneth Starr in
exchange for immunity but why would you
need to have immunity from what if you
didn't tell anybody anything why what
what does it hurt has anyone heard those
tapes
I remember if they did I don't remember
to her plate or not but I know the
information got out there the
information got out there quickly well
that's why it's weird
everybody's attacking Trump that he's a
sexual piece of [ __ ] and he's done all
the stuff which I don't know if he's
done it's alleged right you know of
course and if he's done it he is a piece
of [ __ ] but you know Bill Clinton did
some pretty awful [ __ ] to women too well
yeah I mean I mean that's also alleged
like maybe maybe it's not alleged yeah
but she said like go ahead put a cigar
in my [ __ ] you know what I mean if
somebody's giving you permit eating rape
or with a cigar
well yeah well he did there's alleged
stuff for him to yeah yeah
he has accident hedges all the stuff
that's confirmed about Bill is but he's
not consensual but you're right he's not
a great but you did it you suck ass
alright when you're teaching kids your
kids something yeah you know being the
the leader of the free world sticking
cigars and interns [ __ ] this thing he
may have taken advantage of a power
position he might have good I mean I
don't know if that's good of you know he
might have taken advantage of a young
person that could have a reason to look
up to him yeah
maybe there's something to see it's like
a chubby comic having a good set and
getting a [ __ ] somewhere you know
there's a hot chick right yeah taking
advantage it's literally yeah I don't
know if I would have shoved a cigar in
an intern no no no but I mean fooled
around with her I don't know if you
Monica would have milk your dick so well
ah you think so nursed it it does sound
tempting yeah good girl especially
you're saying any of us would have done
that and we were given that position and
we had wives that had bad body odor
greasy hair and possibly vaginas that
stunk yeah and did one-oh specialist
yeah you're talking about us he admitted
to being a sex addict didn't he no no he
didn't doli doli said he was Holly did
yeah
Dolly Kyle said he was a sex addict said
that she knocked out Jesse Ventura I
mean you know you think the greatest
sniper in the history of the country who
is also having sex is a master disguise
you're saying any of us would do the
same thing that's not really I mean in
this room that's not saying much
right soon as you talk about guys who
are supposed to be better they're
supposed to be better than us you're the
President of the [ __ ] of the free
world you're supposed to be a little
better than three [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
any of us would do the same thing which
is why none of us would ever be able to
close to like demonic is bent over the
the table with their [ __ ] out just
yelling
you really think so yes these are some
of the best sound bites ever by the way
[Laughter]
well I mean he the Donald Trump stuff is
just getting creepier there's a you know
because he's done so much media
everything he's ever done is slowly but
surely yeah coming out coming up - I
want him
yeah but Howard was talking about when
he ran for governor yeah and then he
started to win yeah he was like I'm out
right I'm [ __ ] gone
stop looking I'm out cuz what yeah and
and there someone said that this same
thing might have happened to him or was
like I'll just run for president and
then he started winning and he's like
what the [ __ ] but his ego won't let him
drop out oh yeah he should have got the
[ __ ] out yeah I don't think that he
thought he was gonna win this thing yeah
are you couldn't have like I think he
just went forward being like this would
be great I just like look like I just
get a bunch of press and look like a
million bucks and then as he started
winning you're right his ego does not
allow him it just caught fire cuz he's
writing some opening statement or a
fairly you know poorly said opening
stare and it just resonated with people
right yeah I don't think that anybody
when he first made the Mexican rapists
thing right it's his first speech first
to announce he's running for president
he said we're getting the rapists out of
here and people are like well this is
like a joke right but everybody was like
no no I'm voting for that guy it became
a different thing I said I believe it's
bringing more in we should relieve
Mexico of their problem rapists bringing
more Raymond yeah that's a terrible rata
G why it's helpful we're helpful helpful
to Mexico is everyone but why would it
be helpful to us well I mean let's be
good people get the rapists out of there
bring him here how are you planning a
trip to Acapulco I just want it to be
rape freeze oh no I'm actually on a
vacation right below to Juarez is that
right absolutely that sounds I mean that
sounds like it should be fun it's very
tropical I have this really hot blonde
I'm gonna take down of Juarez meet some
locals yeah I just walk around the
streets the open-air market for fun yeah
down in the clubs yeah get drunk
yeah buy a round of drinks for everyone
yeah
oh good and just put the remaining cash
right back in your pocket right make
sure you [ __ ] with the guy with the the
guitar case with guns in it I'll tell
them do you know who I am I'm very
important back home yeah say this I may
not have a lot of money but my parents
do awesome you should wear a shirt that
says I'm fired
oh you're fired from Donald Trump we're
a Trump shirt Trump hat we're a Trump
wig make America great again
yeah yeah America great again Donald was
on Wendy Williams in 2013 oh and this is
the tape that came out yesterday you
know you're talking about people talking
about Donald Trump being kind of a
sexual predator or not and look if he
forced kisses women which he very well
might do because he's mentioned in a lot
that's not good you can't force kiss
women what about force kissing men force
kissing men it's a sign of dominance and
intimidation right that's okay I'm out
straight I'm the I'm the alpha in this
right I'm sure in a business scenario
Donald has grab somebody by his two fat
cheeks on his face and kissed him right
on the mouth when I'm not one yeah plan
to smooch right here right but you can't
do it to a woman he was on Wendy
Williams though and Wendy asked him I'm
gonna let you guess Bobby because Jim
has seen the clip
Wendy had Ivanka and Donald on at the
same time and he said what are you to
what the question do you have the
question or no the Whydah you want to
just play the question can you do that
Adrienne and pause it alright don't you
[ __ ] this up Adrienne don't you [ __ ]
this up but you talk to him like that
it's important it's important he was
with me first I know but he needs to be
disciplined let me tell you something he
came from you know what dude with a
severe lack of discipline and respect
well cuz he wasn't there long enough
before you sucked him out first of all
he was interning for us before you but
go on to this question from our our guy
yeah Adrienne we want to know a little
bit more about you guys so we play this
game here it's called fave five I'll ask
the question I thought oh you answer
first and then -
okay vodka what's the favorite thing you
have in common with your father either
real estate or golf okay well no we
gotta ask Trump what's the same
questions she asked him or I think he
just throws it right to Trump
it's either real estate or golf what is
your favorite thing that you have in
common with your father
she says Trump said so we didn't make
any sense
why would you say that you just wanted
to hit the button this is where I see
you like the sound bites cuz they've
been in context since you've been here
by but almost every day
they're not in context at all if your
son content just like stop I was in
context he finds excuses to push the
buttons yeah it's kind of addicting like
Hillary's vagina smell yeah not good but
there's something about it going back
yeah what do you think Bobby was the
thing for $10,000 what is the thing that
Donald and Ivanka have in common that is
Donald's favorite horse kissing women
were you think for you think Ivanka
force kisses women as well as you kids
force kisses women and blah and light
blonde pubic hair you think Donald will
say well it's our pubic hair it's the
same yes is it okay well let me care and
taking long unbroken dumps broken long
unbroken dumped comes out like
soft-serve just in that nice even spiral
is that right all right I like one like
a submarine that just sinks right down
the pipe just goes down the pipe and
half of its stick you don't know how
long it is right right now you pull it
out it's it looks like looks like it's
six inches but if you get a little hook
on it I'm gonna an index and pull it out
around a 12 foot long I gotta see how
long it is no just what you wouldn't
want someone to drop down in your mouth
stand up gently on the side a
but if the log falls at your face in the
woods does it make a sound
no you do it it would just stick up and
then slowly gravity pull over on you I
don't like the detail and no shouting I
do say I don't like the [ __ ] the the
little tiny details that they're adding
to this story yeah you know I mean that
would never write like a log stick let's
get back on topic here what do you do
with a log when you're putting your
mouth I imagine you feel like a goose
think so silly
but does it skim your teeth oh god damn
what do you just do you have to put your
lips around your teeth so you don't skim
it the log in your mouth thank you I'm
glad you did that
should we find out what the thing that
Ivanka and Donald have in common that
they the Donald likes the most I say the
same color pubic hair uh-huh and long
jacket Oh head can I guess and long
unbroken poops
now we'll remind everybody Ivanka's she
said golf and real estate yes like a
chip if you want to guess you can feel
free try playing uh [ __ ] monopoly the
thumb because that [ __ ] liking
boardwalk and Park Place is all that
[ __ ] in it
I wish serious would fire him can we
just fire chip it's a positive vibe chip
good chip banned from the building all
right let's find out what Donald likes
so much
Donald well I was going to say sex but I
can't relate that what doesn't even it's
nothing he was just trying to he jammed
a joke in that's all it was
that's like it's one of the Twitter
trolls just trying to jam a fat joke
he's gonna say sex yeah that's crazy
it's not a little creepy yeah well it's
not even it's understandable you yeah do
you think he wants to have sex with his
daughter I don't know I mean no I think
you should I
he sees her as an extension of how
awesome he is because he created such a
beautiful tall woman yeah and he's
sitting there going like how great would
she be to [ __ ] cuz he knows how great he
is to find meaning like look look at
what I created this this amazing piece
of ass didn't he once say that if they
weren't related he'd be dating her he
says that on the view he said that they
made fun of him there's actually a
likable clip of him on the view it
wasn't like a bullet all because he was
like legitimately laughing when they
made fun of him quantum Woody Allen like
he'd they got I mean he left about it it
was funny if it wasn't likable they were
making fun of him cuz he just said he
would date his daughter it's like this
is a this is a great the title of this
YouTube video is Donald Trump nearly
casually remarks about incest with his
daughter but if they put a picture line
it depends on what goes inside if they
were using her - I don't think Ivanka
would do that inside the magazine
although she does have a very nice
figure I've said but if you've anka
weren't my daughter perhaps I'd be
dating her yeah that's not a boys will
be boys mine and that's not like
laughing he's just yeah he's almost like
he's almost Asperger II yeah like but
watch them the gage is laughing at
having a good time of it that's not
that's not something to have a good time
yeah but no cuz you have to have that
thought by yourself yeah to make that
joke yeah you have to have every I
believe every job lies in it like
there's a little tiny truth to it you
had that thought right oh that's funny
right you have to understand what the
truth of that would be understand that
it's funny yeah like the moment that he
says but you know let's be honest she
does have a good figure immediately you
go one
that's something that you would say
about now you can say my domine mothers
say that my son is so hands when they're
like he's gonna pose nude now like
always got a beautiful body you'd be
like what the [ __ ] now but yeah I don't
you mean look but there's a difference
between a little kid like max has a nice
little tush I'd like to take a little
bite once in a while just a little bite
of a Max's bum does he got any friends
you could bring along boy - ish kid hey
you can't leave them kind of bread
crumbs laying around but look at you
look at you can't like when you're
talking about it's a different eye when
you're talking about a little kid he's
cute oh she's gorgeous
you're not talking sack there's no sex
right that's what you had pubes yeah
yeah
yank him out with tweezers I got that
picture in my restaurant the three high
knees I call it it's awful eeny meeny
miny ah ha ha we know who's never gonna
run for president we're never gonna have
an office look at those three meenie
miney uh ha ha this is all I have to
play for did you get Norton out of the
game if he's running for president I
said things in 19 in May of 1998 box.we
series on the hotline sorry I mean it's
a notification of the US of A is
happening yeah yeah but you're right
about the Donnell thing that like
there's something about the way he says
it that like if you were in a room maybe
like yeah as in my daughter [ __ ] sexy
like I'm just appreciating my daughter
but your daughter's too old to say that
you're - you guys are adults and she is
smoking hot I mean it's like you but
you're the guy like it should be like oh
we can't say she's hot and her dad's
here that's true you know that's what
your spretz how it's supposed to go
it's weird right it is a little bit
especially when he's like we both like
sex you know I hope he said I've often
joked if I wasn't Ivana cos father I'd
probably be dating her because when her
legs are phenomenal yeah but if dude
she's amazing she's amazing that she
can't if you're I date her
when you say you're when you're Donald
Trump and you say your date a girl
you're [ __ ] them yeah
first night you're [ __ ] them Donald
doesn't just date you you know I'd take
her out to dinner and walk her to her
car kiss her on the cheek I'm gonna
finger [ __ ] you in my limo yes is what
your baby not a gentleman on the first
day you have to go further with that
thought sure he's really not animals to
his date he has to go could you jump up
and down to my watch falls out she's
beautiful but just even to like you
think he's ever rubbed her feet I think
he has gotten a rod I would I believe
he's rubbed her feet I believe he's
offered his daughter a foot massage like
after a tough day at work yes I believe
that has happened I don't think he's
jerked off to an Adrian but I bet I bet
there was there was something going on
down there she is really stunning what's
her husband like is he like some big
business guy
no he's just an average dude I think
he's probably yeah she's beautiful
he's definitely Jared Kushner
yeah he's Parkinson's get dimple she is
gorgeous i sat behind her at a press
conference once and that was enough it
was enough she's amazing yeah I smelled
their ponytail oh it smells good did you
really yes it's all her things she got
with me her Harry's investment kiyah
I don't think she got a whiff of my hair
why no I was behind her smells like
jheri curl
cherry girl in my ears smells like
[ __ ] nut yeah like cocoa butter yeah
oil he got off the street in front let's
go to Chris in Chicago you want to call
Jim Norton and Sam Roberts this morning
it's eight six six nine six nine one
nine six nine you can follow us on
Twitter at Jim and Sam show the New York
Observer and Robert Kelley is here
morning God and Chris well you know if
you listen back to that clip that he
just played which one the view pipe or
the or the one where he goes I was
[ __ ] liberal Adam
he doesn't say it off the cuff that was
pre-planned how he said that well I
would date my daughter
he had that thought in his head way
before that question came out that's his
line you know what I mean he's like that
that's how he makes other people know
that he's the man he's like you see how
hot my daughter is I would bang her if
she wasn't my daughter yeah but nobody's
around
I'm sorry guys if you had that kind of
comment wouldn't that be something you
just like oh paid off the cuff but he's
had that in his you know arsenal yeah
yes yeah I would have been like yo that
[ __ ] don't fine she looks thin and [ __ ]
he hits the button even though it's him
that's him his button
get off me Edgar it's his the chip
laughter now here's [ __ ] dumb baby
fingernails the chip laughs is now a
button a button yes where are you from
Harry Potter's magic button hey let me
ask you that camera you had off subject
for one second that camera you're at the
comedy show you know it's good is that
order or can i buy that in a store you
can um you can't buy it in a store you
have to order it it's called the Mevo
okay and you have one hour do you have
one here you just take that one they
don't use it yeah there's an Evo here
there's an Evo here just take that one
yellow whip it's good vivo vivo yeah
they have it yeah thank you God I'm
gonna bite your fingernails clean [ __ ]
hey there's dry mouth yeah they brought
him in here but the resolutions not as
good as those but it'd be good for
Setzer I might want to do it because
they might might die I need to shoot
myself to show my person unit you gonna
shoot your special on them yes
vivo you go let's go to Frank you know
Jersey what's up Frank East Brunswick
here representing uh Jim North was like
listen to me the funny thing is about
transfers know what I know I was a
girlfriend what was it give me right
shut the [ __ ]
hey listen uh Trump's daughter's husband
was put in jail by chris Christie
Trump's daughter's husband's father
rather is a crooked politician money
laundering a why not and he was point he
was put in jail 15 years by Chris
Christie which is ironic as Chris
Christie it's supporting Trump oh yeah
maybe that's why he didn't become the VP
because he put his Trump son-in-law in
jail technically we're the father the
brother the son-in-law whatever the [ __ ]
relationship that is he didn't become
the VP because I mean maybe that went
into it don't you think [ __ ] good
Trump has gotten chubby yes yes he's
back to when he was in when he fought in
WWE when he fell which is a terrible
bump
he was who's he beat no is you beaten up
man Vince he went thing clothesline him
and his whole body just fell over
but remember his ass remember how big is
I was it looked like a fat woman ass
yeah yeah just jiggled on the way down
we watched him when we watch the debates
in here you can see that it's such a
wide ass he's got he has a big
comfortable chair honey he does mmm yeah
he does it's meant for a throne he did
yeah he really does have [ __ ] oh no
go back to the beginning you want to see
athleticism Jim look at a look at
Trump's big bump
[Laughter]
it looks like he's punching him he was
punched him was really why is he wearing
a suit in wrestling there's the Battle
of the billionaire's Jim that battery
but you have to wear suit can't be a
billionaire and not of a suit oh my god
where'd my cheese go DDT is that the
lyrics to the song do that damn it
that's not the lyrics to the song at all
yeah one two three
[Music]
you like this Bobby teff box is moving
in there right now love this you know
people keep asking us to play the
profane version of that song I don't
want to I didn't know there was one to
be on there is there's a form to use
that with profanity and I don't I don't
I don't necessarily want to know just
part one I think we're good with with
what we got
but yeah so uh Donald is there there's
some there's some there's some weirdness
there's some weirdness and he has that
weird white guy like Mason creepiness
about him that yeah the you know just
the naked if you saw him naked
what is he mail this photo of him
I've seen this a bunch of time it's
Ivanka when she's like how old you say
13 14 maybe yeah her face looks very
young but she's tall so she looks older
she's face looks really young she's
sitting on Donald's lamp and or she's
sitting on his knee and Donald's got his
hand on her hip and she's got her she's
cupping his face or is he supposed to
put it it's just such a it seems
inappropriate don't you think her too
loving a look her cupping his face and
looking at him longingly
well this idolizes afar but I thank you
photographers sometimes get carried away
yeah I mean me and Don we've got married
in Maui we're on the beach yeah and
after the you know we're doing our photo
shoot after we got married and they kept
telling us to deuce
go do this do that oh go on the tree
line go in the water all of a sudden
we're in the water
she's like Oh pick a dress and you're
just listening to him cuz you thought
you could you believe you hired him you
believe them you trust them yeah it's
like I'm honey the lady just told me to
pull your dress up I'm not pulling my
wives what are you nuts
not what's our wedding day you [ __ ]
weirdo that kodesh always what hot
[ __ ] are made of it's a terrible idea
yeah but we were like I started I have
one photo of us in the water and I'm
pulling up her
leg-oh yeah it up like she's getting
naked [ __ ] yeah
not me of course no oh yeah we ruined
her [ __ ] dress oh yeah come on and
[ __ ] no no come on it's chip you're
totally on the wrong direction here I'm
married you don't [ __ ] on your wedding
night did you should do right yeah you
have to do have to yes I remember I
would carried her in and I hit you know
the hotel doors mm-hmm in the movies
they just kick him open and they stay
open
yeah in real life in real life they
[ __ ] swing shut bad kick the door and
we're going in the door just watch lucky
she didn't get killed as [ __ ] why would
she get killed by a hotel door every
character stinks the worms they just are
the worst through their words
[ __ ] literally not just screeching
halt [ __ ] eight people going
everybody else is turning the radio off
yeah going back to sports talk they are
a set of Cubs one last night [ __ ] I
ain't him hey Edgar out of all of them
you're the Cubbies I like when I say yes
they cubby scalp the tribe I said that
you didn't say that you just made up
just now you can't say that cubby scalp
the tribe v one speak another copy you
want to see the Cubs win though cuz uh
but then again the Indians I'm wanted
[ __ ] 60 years block the Indians they
won they just won basketball this they
just guys Cleveland's [ __ ] you doubt you
know if I like the Cubbies to excel like
Chicago I'm saying not you keep saying I
want to see them win and I go you do and
you go now but I also like like I'm big
on Chicago my Chicago accent flip-flop
Frank you ever met him wait wait do you
know how to do a Chicago accent I never
heard yeah hey Darrin cubbies are in the
old series area might win the ballgame
Travis your baseball guy right yeah does
anybody call the World Series the old
series the cubbies are in there looks
like they're gonna hit a bunch of home
runs what is that I mean probably what
dialect is that some Chicago what part
of Chicago
all over the whole thing sure hump they
sound like an energy Rob Blagojevich
know that okay that is authentic sounds
enough it could be like anywhere no it's
not
it could be Pittsburgh I feel like
Sebastien he's a heavy Chicago accent
Sebastian Maniscalco as a comedian no he
doesn't sound he sounds like an Italian
hey I'm over there he doesn't number one
bunch of homers he doesn't sound like
that number two he doesn't have a very
Chicago accent actually there's hints of
it no it's heavy do you hear him talk I
went to Kmart [ __ ] Chicago bury you
in cement action if he wasn't a comic I
would think that he was a [ __ ] geyser
let's go to Scott in Chicago what's
going on Scott impression is spot-on
thank you so good you think there was
like a whole deep-dish pizza thing okay
cubbies are in a series you took this
Chicago people from Chicago don't just
sit around talking about deep-dish the
time when you say deep-dish pizza stinks
[Laughter]
Chicago Al Capone yet Chicago has great
food unbelievable food got one of the
best food cities a little deep-dish
pizza rolls Chicago pizzas you should be
ashamed of that the Cubbies are playing
ball in the old series I love Bobby
trying to make a point in Chicago Jim
coming in and I can't wait till the day
that Jim just short-circuits and just
all the characters come out at once I
can't wait till somebody puts him in a
home yeah just like a straitjacket like
who's those guys you know all the
impression guys you know talking are
either dead or in the st. Asylum here's
what's gonna be great
he's gonna short-circuit all of his
characters are gonna come out at once
then he's just gonna stop responding his
brain is brain and body was no longer
be connected I will wheel him in here in
a wheelchair every morning as you do the
show let's go shall we
what would you say that if you had
couldn't go on Scott all right I just
wanted to admonish everybody in Chicago
for not coming out and seeing Bobby
Kelly when he was in town a couple weeks
ago he was awesome thank you buddy
you're great I was the first guy to take
a picture with you and I told you I
brought my wife with and I've been in
trouble ever since because she's like he
did a lot of [ __ ] stuff
you do wanna climb hilarious to me yeah
so happy to see you man please come back
Oh get all you guys to come to Chicago I
feel like you know Jimmy comes once
every year years and we should go to
radio show yeah I would love to eat
Chicago hopefully we'll have people come
to see I love what to come yeah now you
ain't lying you're gonna I do have like
20 minutes of my new hours like I just
call it jizz you're dirty
it's I it's clean a lot of it's a lot of
Jews
[Laughter]